this 2000 redshift section where we'll
take an overview of cameras and redshift
Amazon redshift is a fast fully managed
petabyte scale data warehouse that makes
it simple and cost-effective to analyze
all your data using your existing
business intelligence tools redshift is
a great choice if your database is
overloaded due to OLAP transactions as
mentioned earlier Amazon redshift is
designed for OLAP which allows you to
easily combine multiple complex queries
to provide answers relational or sequel
databases are row based however redshift
is a column based database so if you
look at this diagram at the top is a
table width as you would see in an Excel
spreadsheet so you have country product
and sales and then all the different
rows and then a relational database
would store this Towers Row 1 would be
countries India product is chocolate
sales is 1000
however in column based databases is
done differently so all the countries
would be stored together so you'd have
India India Chilean us stored then you
store the products then you store the
sales and this is the key difference
between row store and column store
databases this means that columnar data
is stored sequentially on the storage so
it requires less read to get all the
data and it also allows you to compress
your data columnar data can be pressed
much easier as all the data types are
the same because we had country all
stored in one sequential row so it's
much easier to compress in row based all
the data types would be different so
compression is much harder
the compression scheme for redshift is
automatically chosen for you so you
don't even have to worry about that
an Amazon redshift data warehouse is a
collection of computing resources called
nodes and these nodes are organized into
a group called a cluster and each
cluster runs an Amazon redshift engine
that contains one or more databases when
you first launch Amazon redshift you can
start with a single node 160 gigabytes
in size then as you grow you can add
additional nodes to take advantage of
massive parallel processing and you can
then operate a multimode and what this
means is you have a leader node which
manages all the client connections and
then the compute nodes these store data
and perform queries and connotations and
you can have up to 128 compute nodes one
of the limitations of DynamoDB is that
it's not highly available as it's only
available in one availability zone the
reason for this is that management
business intelligence is not viewed as
business critical it's something that
would be brought up very quickly but
there would be other applications needed
to be brought up first you can however
restore snapshots of your Revit chefs
databases to other availability zones
let's take a look at the cost associated
with redshift firstly you're charged for
the number of compute node hours that
you use and that doesn't include the
lead-in though the leader node is not a
chargeable node also you're charged for
the backups that you store and also any
data transfers within your V PC you're
not charged for any transfers outside of
the V PC
hey once become an expert in cloud
computing then subscribe to simpler
Channel and click here to watch more
such videos turn it up and get certified
in cloud computing click here